[Music]
we have arrived at the very first
major in the champions chess tour that
means
more prize money bigger nerves and more
drama
we will be here every move of the way in
the everything's monsters to give you
all the mouth slips
the time trouble and all the genius
moves
so wherever you are in the world welcome
to the very first day of the air things
monsters
welcome to my humble abode this time
i'll be playing from moscow but here is
where i live
[Music]
and i just want to see how he's
suffering
[Music]
this is my usual work spot power
you need a very good mouth there's the
old mouse i use for all the other
tournaments
it can be a little bit dark in here
certainly try to be in killer mode from
the get-go
for winning the skilling open is not
enough i need some more
everything's monsters is the second
tournament in the champions chess tour
but it is the first major that means 12
players will be
fighting out over the course of the next
nine days now we have
great chest players in the studio to
help us understand everything that will
be going on women's grandmaster ivanka
houska
and grandmaster david howell and david
we're feeling
festive and for many people it is the
holidays can you think of
any better way to spend the holidays
than watching the best chess players in
action
no i've been looking forward to this for
weeks already i spent the whole of my
christmas getting excited about these
games
i'm sure the players too they spent
their christmases preparing and
hopefully all the viewers at home um i
mean you've chosen a good way to spend
your christmas your boxing day
definitely and ivanka the first major in
the champions chester what do you expect
from the players now
oh we are gonna be in for a treat you
know i think the players will come
out ready and fighting and we're going
to see some splendid attacks
and also i think on the flip side we're
going to see the players
under a lot of pressure it's going to be
so
much fun here in the studio and also i
think for everyone at home
and we want everyone to partake in this
fun and you can get involved in the
conversation
by tweeting us using the hashtag
chesschamps they will be shown
on the screen and even perhaps read out
on the show definitely
so excited to have everyone join us on
twitter and now
uh air things masters we have nine days
of chess ahead of us what will these
nine days look like
oh they're gonna it's gonna be so so so
good i cannot stress enough okay so our
12
players will first of all play a
preliminary event which will be an
11 a player or 11 round all play all
and then the top only the top eight go
on through
to the knockout stages so this will be
two days of quarter-finals semi-finals
and then
we get to the big wanakaya where the
winner of the air things
masters will walk away with sixty
thousand dollar first prize
and a golden ticket to the grand final
in september
exactly so much at stake in the air
things monsters now david we did get to
know the time control in the first
tournament
rapid chess now what does this mean
that's right so rapid chess
the players will have 15 minutes on
their clock for the whole game
if they run out of time they lose they
will however gain 10 seconds
after every move so there's a bit of
leeway but when the clock ticks down
it will get exciting as ivanka mentioned
12 players they'll play each other once
so 11 rounds
and one point for a win half point for a
draw only the top eight qualify
four players go home four players go
home after three days now
we did mention this is the second
tournament in the champions chester in
the first one
world champion magnus carlsen of course
he was the big favorite he did reach the
final
but it was wesley saw who won the
scaling open
we're going to see everything hoovered
off the board we're going to see king
versus king
and wesley's done and you can see that
let's look at wesley
right now he is the winner of the
skilling open
i'm very happy and very pleased i'm
excited to play again
the last tournament was unexpected i'm
getting more and more used to
the covid lifestyle of staying at home
and playing online
before the pandemic hit i rarely played
online chess
i didn't even have a good mouse i didn't
even have a large monitor
look at black's bishop he's captured
upon those two white rooks are attacked
one has lost one of his rooks magnus
carson i think he's going to give up any
moment
before this really hickory and the
magnus who are the big dogs in online
chess but in the last tournament i
managed to get lucky and beat both of
them in one tournament so that's really
a big deal for my confidence
i'm in no way thrilled with the the way
that i i played in that tournament
it was a massive struggle from from
start to finish
i'll certainly try to be in killer mode
from the get-go
[Music]
all right magnus carlsen is in revenge
mode david do you think this was a big
blow for him
not winning the scaling open that's
right i think he's just so used to
winning at this point he's won
everything there is to win and over
again um and
um yeah i think it'll be a big blow to
his ego he'll want to put things right
in this tournament
and let's uh now take a look at the
standings in the champions chester after
that
very first uh tournament we do have
wesley saw on the top here ivanka
is that surprising in any way well it
was surprising because we all
expected magnus carson to win but you
know where's he so paid brilliant chess
and fully deserves that poor
spot but of course many many of the top
names of the world you know these
are some of the world's best fighting
most uncompromising players
so i'm expecting that leaderboard to
perhaps shift a little bit
we see hikaru nakamura yana pomnyacci
third there david who do you think is
most eager and most hungry
to really fight to climb on this
standings table that's right the two you
mentioned nakamura another born winner
he wants to win
everything there is to win nepomniacci
he had a great break actually between
the skilling open and this air things
masters he managed to win the russian
championship
so he will be on a high he will be
looking to push towards those top spots
all right well as this is a major we
have 12 players fighting in the air
things monsters eight of them
qualified from the scaling open now
let's take a look at the eight
top players in their things masteries
[Music]
ian nepomniacci born in the same year as
magnus carlsen the russian number one
was ahead of the reigning world champ
as a youngster but he has since seen
carlson forge on
despite building up an impressive plus
four score against his rival
winning the champions chess tour is well
within his grasp
maksim vashir lagrave the french number
one from leon oozes style and
sophistication in his play
and is capable of beating anyone but he
has had a succession of near misses in
top events
levon aronian armenia's number one
has had a tough year seeing the tragic
death of his wife
and his home country embroiled in war
but aronian is back with positive energy
the famously laid-back armenian is seen
as the joker in the pack of world chess
a supremely creative player who can
better anyone
on his day wesley soh
the winner of the first tournament in
the champions chess tour
so hit world number two in 2016
and was talked about as the next big
thing in chess
and a potential world champion he also
had a stunning
67 game unbeaten streak but since then
hasn't quite lived up to the hype yet
timor rajabov born in the same city as
the great gary kasparov
timor rajabov burst onto the scene as a
hugely exciting youngster
but as a rising star he failed to live
up to his promise
and seemed to lose his attacking verve
now 33 rajabov who has been badly
affected this year by war
in his home country is firmly back on
track
hikaru nakamura the most obvious threat
to magnus carlson's crown
the american speed chess king took the
world champion to
a thrilling armageddon playoff in the
final of the magnus carlson chess tour
nakamura is the world's top blitz player
with an incredible rating of 2 900.
anish giri is somewhat harshly known for
the amount of drawers he racks up
but his chest is extremely solid making
him almost unbeatable
like grandmaster arkhadich nadic once
said
beating magnus carlsen is easier than
beating anish kerry
magnus carlsen the norwegian king of
chess has been called everything from
the justin bieber of chess
to the mozart of chess carlson has to
fight for his reputation
in every game he has won everything
but lost the final in the first
tournament in the champions chess tour
to wesley so and will be eager for
revenge
magnus carlsen he is in revenge in beast
mode before their things monsters
we do also have four wild cards ivanka
in this tournament now
who are these four that we should look
out for oh these
are great exciting players you know we
have alexander
grishik three-time blitz world champion
and we also have a russian
danny dubois very famous for his
creative style he's so aggressive
and then we have pantala hare krishna he
is missed attention give him a
complicated position he loves it and of
course we have
david anton who was the big underdog who
did amazingly well in the skilling open
last month so these guys are super
exciting
super strong definitely not to be
underestimated
definitely and david anton he did play
the skilling open uh he was knocked out
in the preliminaries but was voted back
in
by the viewers and he will be competing
in their things masters
along with these three others other wild
cards
david anton spain's reigning champion
is a hugely popular figure in the chess
world known for being a nice guy
and he did impress in the first
champions chess tour tournament
alexander grieschuk at 37 griez is
almost a veteran campaigner
but this three-time world blitz champion
is not slowing down anytime soon daniel
the young russian who announced himself
on the elite stage by becoming world
blitz champion in 2018
is one of the finest talents in chess
pantala hari krishna he won the world
u10
championship in 1996 became a grand
master at 15
and crowned his junior achievements in
2004
by becoming the first indian player
since vishyanand
to win the world junior championship
hari krishna the last of the four wild
cards david so many exciting players 12
of the very strongest players in the
world
fighting in their things monsters that's
right i can't wait to get started those
wild cards as well i've battled them so
many times they're so good they've all
beaten me at some point in my career
um yeah and the clock's ticking we're
almost there round one
looks ticking you said it david and
actually we've been talking about the
time control of course very interesting
but another thing that is so interesting
with the champions chess store players
playing at home all over the world and
that means also
that the clock from where they're
sitting is very interesting look at this
map
i mean hikaru nakamura it's almost it's
six a.m in the morning for him
that is insanely early especially for a
chess player
we're not used to playing getting up so
early that's for starters
that's right chess players night owls so
i think that's going to be a huge
handicap for nakamura and also wesley so
it's not quite 8 a.m for him so it'll be
fascinating to see how the players adapt
who who who is this the best for playing
from home
who who should be comfortable with the
clock here probably the guys in europe
i'd reckon i mean it's afternoon for
them they've had time to wake up shower
do a preparation
um that being said all of the players
they're very professional
they'll have they'll have known this in
advance and they'll have been setting
their body clocks accordingly
and we do we do notice magnus carlsen
the norwegian in the corner here
he's not placed in norway we don't know
where he is no
we certainly don't know where he is but
he has been very active
on social media posting beautiful
pictures of a tropical location
so wherever he is he's having a good
time it's definitely not norway it was
snowing here today
yeah send in your thoughts as well i
mean i i have no idea where he could be
yeah exactly you know definitely who do
you think is a disadvantage and
if you want to get involved in the
conversation please tweet
us using the hashtag chesschamps hashtag
chess champs now
magnus carlson we don't know where he is
sitting right now
in the world but he is in some sort of
hotel room or something and he is
one of the players that we will follow
in the very first round
of the air things monsters this is the
game that we will start off with it is
world champion magnus carlson against
one of his big rivals
lavon neroni and david these two have
met each other so many times that's
right hundreds of times
i mean in speeches alone in rapid and
blitz chess they've beaten each other
more times than i can count i think uh
magnus has said in interviews
uh levon aronian he's outplayed him more
than anyone else in the world
so a big battle ahead and here we have
the two players they have arrived at the
board we see magnus carlsen sitting
with the white pieces lavon ironian is
going to be playing
with the black pieces it is about to
start only one minute away from the get
roll oh do you think the players are
feeling now you've got guys
well levon just left us for a few
seconds he did just leave us and
we yeah we see magnus carlsen getting in
the zone getting
ready to click on that mouse and make
those opening moves
it's certainly looking quite exciting to
be there i'm just looking around by
getting ready i mean i have to say
having played online chess
you do have to set yourself into the
into the mood because
honestly playing at home is quite a
little bit of unusual experience because
you're at home you know you're sitting
in your living room and then
time's up get up there in front of the
computer and get into chess mode
exactly and we and we do know they have
to practice with this mouse david
it is different than playing over the
board chess obviously that's right i
mean
in the skilling open the first event of
the champions chess tour last month
we saw in the first round magnus carlsen
had this horrible mouth slip
he just dropped his queen on the wrong
square and had to immediately resign so
definitely i think the players they will
have been practicing and they will be
very aware that they need to get
in the flow they need to make sure that
the mind and the hand they're
they're in sync we definitely also don't
want something that we call i
actually call myself trigger happy hand
which is where your hand makes the move
before your brain has actually
registered that
remember what you're having so you don't
want to treat your happiness you do not
want to trigger happy hand you have to
take that moment just to go
no no then
right well we are seconds away from the
start of the first
major in the champions chester and we
have started david
magnus made his move that's right so
magnus carlsen playing white he's pushed
the pawn forward in front of his queen
um yeah very traditional opening here
levon replying very quickly magnus
develops his knight towards the center
levon occupies the center with a pawn
and now develops his bishop as black
we'll see a flurry of moves here
we're going to see some very quick play
this has transposed to a line of the
queen's gambit
the queen's gambit declined um for some
of you at home you might have seen the
netflix series
as well the queen's gambit this is that
opening and both players will be
very well prepared in this position we
should also mention
as well the layout of the screen that
you guys at home that you see
in front of you just above the two
players is a small
purple bar and this bar will show what
the computer thinks
of the position the rough evaluation if
it goes towards the left if it goes
towards magnus carlsen's side it means
that white is doing quite well
white is winning or has an advantage if
it goes towards the other way
um yeah then level everyone is doing
well yeah you're doing well
we will see big swings at some point
yeah we will definitely see that and
especially as the clock starts ticking
down
and both players developing their pieces
because one of the goal in the opening
is just to get your pieces developed
and then once you get that and then the
king into safety then
like the opening is officially over and
then we reach to a stage called
middle game where players start hatching
their plans and we did see with that
last move by
levon aronian both magnus has started
thinking for the first time in the game
and also
the bar swinging to his side but but 0.7
advantage for magnus
it's not we can't say he's winning yet
no we can't say he's winning just yet
but i'm just
giggling a little bit because i suddenly
looking at the player's webcam
um well not he started sitting back
and started making some unusual gestures
so he seems to be very happy with his
position
and almost seems to saying right this is
my preparation
magnus what are you going to do that's
right so maybe if we bring up the
analysis board we can explain what's
been happening in this opening and why
magnus carson is taking a pause here we
see that black's last move
was to develop this bishop this bishop
has come out
black's other bishop as well is doing a
nasty thing that we call a pin
the white knight cannot move because the
bishop this black bishop has x-ray
vision towards white's king
now we see a couple of well very
aggressive moves
we see that white has brought his queen
out to attack this bishop
and black has defended it with his queen
we normally don't see the queens enter
the game too early the queens are the
most
valuable piece so you want to keep her
nice and safe in this early stage
because every time she'll get she gets
attacked she'll have to run away
that being said i think both players
have developed very nicely and now it's
about who can get their king to safety
stage
exactly so much tension in the position
with these pins oh
and we have another attack so magnus has
night on the rim yes he has put this
knight on the rim which is dim
normally but the knight is now attacking
this
bishop so lebron has to has to take a
decision as to what to do with that
bishop
to move it forward move it back move it
away
that's right so that white knight we
said knights on the rim are dim
nights on the edge fallout um there's
lots of rhymes but
normally that knight will not want to
stay there actually levon he's retreated
his bishop that bishop
is protected by a couple of pawns
white's knight on the side of the board
there
we see can actually still capture the
bishop but a bishop and a knight they're
both roughly worth three points
they're roughly similar pieces in terms
of value
but they do completely different jobs so
that's always a really interesting trade
personally i love my bishops i just love
those long diagonals
especially when you have a pair of them
together controlling the light squares
and the dark squares
so i like that transition for magnus if
he captures black's bishop now
yeah but it's still very tense and the
center is blocked but you know david
this
is a new move no one has allowed their
bishop to be exchanged off
so yeah we are entering into completely
new territory here and here we have it
on the board that knight has captured
the bishop
and we have a very unbalanced position
now it's going to be all about the
bishop being better than a knight
that's right and maybe we can bring up
the board again because i think
there's a new factor in the position
black's rook
on this side of the board has now been
opened up this is an open line
we've talked a bit about knights and
bishops knights are very good at jumping
around bishops are very good on their
diagonals but rooks
they love open lines black's rook might
want to stay
on that corner square now and white's
king will never feel safe
if it edges towards this side because it
will always be eyed up by the black rook
so
i like what's just happened for levon um
okay we see that magnus carson's just
pushed a pawn in front of
uh his rook there just keeping that pawn
nice and safe trying to block this black
rook in the corner
very tense stuff both players will now
need to get their king to safety but the
problem is
where it's not clear what um
could it actually be hacking could it
actually happen that we we have a game
where they don't castle
this is it is possible it is you know
that always carries an element of risk
because you really do want your king
behind pawns and you want to get the
rooks mobilized so if you have your king
in the center
it can be a bit of a nuisance but it is
entirely possible if it's not safe
to castle or to go to the wings then
okay
it's gonna have to stay in the center
and we are going to see a lot of very
exciting chests
nice that's right as long as the center
is blocked actually in the middle of the
board there we see a couple of pawns a
white horn a black horn
in those central squares as long as the
center is blocked the king is
kind of safe in the middle but it will
never feel entirely safe until it's
behind a
wall of pawns that's why later hopefully
we'll see it we'll explain it if we do
see it we'll see one side castle
perhaps they'll bring their king to
safety behind some pawns
meanwhile magnus carson just pushing a
bishop towards the center there
that's i mean just a very useful move he
wants to use all of his pieces
he wants to collect his rooks as well
connecting the rooks yeah um often gives
a lot more flexibility later in the game
yeah and magnus as well he's such a big
fan
of oh before i dive into that there is
now
maximum attention on the board because
lavonne has advanced
the pawn to attack uh magnus's
carlsenborn and not only that he
has a threat in the air so super
exciting
that's right ivanka if we bring up the
board we can see the threat that levon
and ironian has created
and also he's got more time than he
started with he's got more than 15
minutes
ivanka mentioned it's a new position but
he's playing so quickly he must have
prepared
and this last move levon pushed his pawn
forward he's threatening to push it
forward again
one square if the pawn comes forward one
square it will attack the white queen it
will attack the white bishop
and that pawn will win a piece pawns
they're only worth one point if he wins
a bishop for it worth three points
that's a huge material gain and in reply
magnus carlsen launches a counter-attack
he pushes his pawn forward attacking the
black bishop
so this is very tense both sides
creating threats now
um yeah it'll be fascinating to see
whether levon aronian he studied this uh
this position beforehand
it is levon aronian thinking okay we're
very excited to see his next
move i can uh quickly mention that in
between the other games that is going on
we have
hari krishna facing bachelorette daniel
dubo against timor ajabov
and then we have david anton versus the
the winner of the skilling open wesley
so and anishkiri he's facing
ianaponyachi very interesting game there
and then alexander grishak
is playing against takara nakamura so we
will of course let you know
what happens in those games as well as
we are waiting for a live on ironian
to make his move if he will actually
move this pawn
yeah that's right he could push that
pawn forward he could also
uh black's bishop is now attacked that
so that bishop could trade itself for a
night
giving check to the white king i think
he will move that bishop
it's just there are a couple of options
and we expect him to
spend a long time actually one thing
that my eye is drawn towards immediately
is you mention those other games kaia
at the bottom of the screen below the
players we can see kind of
updates on how the other games are going
and
in the game giri against nepomniacci the
bar
the arrow has gone all the way towards
white side towards spanish giri's side
so maybe we'll see an early result there
soon wow okay we will definitely keep an
eye on that and as
uh levon ronian is uh thinking okay what
did he do he didn't move the pawn
that's right not yet not yet it's still
very much in the air instead in fact he
retreated
the bishop he wanted to preserve a
bishop because you know
one of the great imbalances in chess is
like two bishops two bishops together
are
so good they can control the whole board
and uh lebron did not want to allow
magnus that and so he decided to keep
one of his bishops on the board
and still there is that question what is
magnus going to do about the center what
is he going to do with attention
so many options yeah and talking of
tension those queens are actually
looking at each other right now
we could be about to see a queen trade
magnus carlsen's queen white's queen is
not defended right now
so he either has to move it or he has to
run away or he has to trade queens
magnus carlsen we saw it in the skilling
open in the last tournament of the
championship he's so good at his end
games
so normally trading queens i think it's
something he he quite likes and then we
see the queens have disappeared wow that
was fast
very fast um and actually i think we saw
something that we call a pre-move
um in internet chess that means that
with the mouse you
make the move beforehand in anticipation
of your opponent's move
so for example levon aronian he would
have clicked his bishop he would have
clicked
his queen so assuming that magnus took
that he'd make the move immediately he
wouldn't lose any time on the clock
wow that's another difference with okay
so that's another thing you can actually
practice before
before these tournaments just clever
small things to just spare a little bit
of time
exactly you can certainly save a lot of
time which is very very important when
it comes to a situation like the
armageddon where no time is added on the
clock you do
need to be a specialist in these
pre-moves but you've got to be very very
careful because if you make the wrong
pre-move
that's it you've made a blunder of the
worst proportions and it's game over
so actually levon aronian here is
showing both he's clever he's he's done
his preparation
and he does feel confident yes he's
certainly looking confident look at his
body posture on the chair he just
looks completely in the zone he knows
this is preparation
and uh this is what he's been practicing
all right well
magnus carlsen is now thinking and we
said so many times imagine we want to
involve the viewers that
we want them to join in on the fun here
in the studio and we do
i think you've prepared a quiz for them
haven't you we do
have a quiz yes and uh the question
we do have a quiz and the prize will be
a year's premium membership of
chess 24 which is absolutely amazing
and here is the quiz so let me just
have to inch forward who is the reigning
world fisher random champion yes
so yeah do we any of us know the answer
i think i actually know the answer but
no you're not allowed to say david i
know i know you like
showing off but you're not allowed to
say so if you at home know the question
or if you're able to find out the
question then tweet us on the
on the hashtag chesschamps with your
answer we will pick a winner within the
end of today
and the winner will get a one year
premium membership bunch has 24. so
please get into twitter and let us know
if you know the answer who is the
reigning fisher random world champion
yes that's a great prize as well
actually i was asked by so many people
who've
kind of they've only discovered chess
recently they've only just got into
chess and they asked
you know what should i or should i get
my friend another chess player
um what should i get them for christmas
as a christmas present and i thought
what better than a chess 24 premium
membership you get to watch so many
videos
um on demand you get so many perks and
you can even
challenge at the top players because the
two players will come on like magnus
carlsen where he'll be like doing banter
blitz where he's like come on
play me and oh you can only challenge if
you're a premium
member and where else in the world can
you
get the opportunity to play against the
world
champion you might lose
any sport that's not even possible in
any sport no i know
chess is possible and the world champion
has made his move what's happening david
that's right so we've seen not just the
queen sleeve the board but also a pair
of pawns
white has well he's lost his central
pawn in return
um i mean it was a fair exchange a pawn
for a pawn black now though
his knight has leaped forward black's
knight is attacking a white bishop in
the center here
um maybe if we bring the board up we can
just see well we've seen castling as
well magnus carson he's got his king to
safety finally
finally um 16 moves into the game that's
very late normally for those of you at
home if you're new to chess get your
king to safety very quickly and this is
something magnus carlsen has just done
on the last move we saw white's king
in the center here white's rook there's
nothing between those two pieces
neither piece has moved yet either so
therefore white can castle he brings his
king two squares across
the king always moves two squares if you
want to castle the other way the king
moves two squares across as well and
then the rook jumps over
so you activate two well you get your
king to safety this king will
hide itself behind a white pawn and you
activate your rook at the same time
it's a bit of a bonus move bit of a
cheap move you get to use two
uh two pieces at the same time and
that's the only moment you can do it in
the game
and as a bonus magnus carson he's using
his rook now to defend this bishop which
was attacked by the black knight
um yeah i like that move by magnus
we see that the bar slightly favors
white as well i think
that white has a slightly better
position just because his pieces are
more ready for the action than blacks
yeah i agree with you david i'm really
liking magnus's position
and there's actually something very
tangible in the air because normally
what you want to do is you want to start
planning you want to you know
you want to think about what pieces to
attack what pieces to defend what
lines to possess and here i think magnus
will be
having his eyes on one pawn that is
totally unsupported and it's all alone
so when you have such a pawn like that
they can be very strong but they can
also be
very very weak and what i'm gonna what
i'm expecting magnus to do
is basically play with a one-track mind
which is
pile up everything on that pawn control
it make sure it can't run away
and uh yep then try and eat it basically
that's right
that black pawn in the center it looks
so lonely next to it
i think the battle will revolve around
the center as it always does
in chess but especially around that pawn
and actually just below the players this
time we see
the computer evaluation the stockfish is
one of the strongest
analysis engines out there one of the
strongest computer programs out there
and it does give white a small advantage
that being said black if he moves his
rook across now
he could also castle with his king um
just like magnus carlsen has done
um the advantage is manageable i think
black his position is okay it's solid
um not too much going on right now but
the problem is this pawn in the center
of the board black
okay black cop is white um when in doubt
copy your opponent
[Laughter]
and levon aronian also castles his king
towards that left side of the wood
um it's a bit symmetrical in terms of
the kings the rooks
but it's all going to revolve around the
pieces in the middle will whites bishops
be better than the black knights
will that pawn drop off yeah
exactly a lot to think about and uh yeah
i do think that
lebron perhaps will be a little slightly
uncomfortable because he's so
he's such a traditional player he really
likes to have
really good pawns he likes to have his
pieces well developed it would be a
little bit uncomfortable for him to have
such a bad pawn that's
all alone in the center but he has to
offset that weakness in another way by
either getting
really good pieces or and finding good
squares for those
nights and david really said that he has
to start making those
knights start jumping around putting
them in good posts
preferably on the bottom half of the
board because i like to split the board
in half i like to have
the bottom half belongs to white the top
half belongs to black
and i think both sides should be quite
possessive about their own halves and
any piece that comes in
you kind of go no kick it away
and i think i think lebron will try to
make use of those two those two nights
and uh try to find a post
preferably on the bottom half of the
board that's right there's four
first four ranks um at the bottom there
white white at the moment has good
control
no black pieces have infiltrated into
that half but the black knights are
edging further forward and that's why
maybe we saw magnus carlsen
a moment ago he lent back he kind of
flinched a bit
he didn't look too happy maybe he's just
trying to figure out how to keep as much
tension as possible
there's a slight risk once queens leave
the board that lots
lots more pieces if they do get traded
the game will fizzle out to a draw and
magnus he said beforehand he wanted to
enact
killer mode um and without the queens
that's very hard
he won't be going for checkmate he'll
just be going for a slong slump
[Laughter]
i'm so excited by the game
positional slow and long long
a long strategic grind that's what i
wanted to say so strong then
a strong long grind
it can't be that long because he doesn't
have all that much time on the clock he
has spent uh
quite a lot more time than lavon aronian
so far do you think uh
the world champion will get into some
time trouble here
he's five minutes down already and
actually uh that's rare to see from
magnus carson he's normally quite quick
quite confident
that's a sign that he's not fully uh
comfortable with the position
right now he's not sure um how he can
create those winning chances how he can
kind of put that pressure on levon
ironian aronian playing so quick
and confident that being said i have
played iranian many times before and
sometimes he does bluff
against me he's he plays very very
quickly sometimes they're not always the
best moves but he likes to put that
psychological pressure
on the opponent's end oh we have a noise
and a ding is telling us that the king
has
sidestepped so very interesting move i
wouldn't necessarily have expected that
i would perhaps expect something to do
with that rook
that's on the right side that's not
quite working but yeah
interesting that's right so white just
with that last move
it doesn't look like the most ambitious
move but it's a very useful one to make
just tucking that king into the corner
nice and safe white's king will never be
in trouble now
especially the queen's having left the
board um that being said
it's going to be all about whether white
can activate that rook in the bottom
right hand corner that iranka mentioned
that rook at the moment is the only
piece doing nothing for white
meanwhile blacks rooks black knight
bishop they all look quite nicely placed
quite centralized the black king i'm
very surprised actually that he
did decide to copy magnus on that last
turn the black king can't copy white
this time the black king can't
shuffle across one square because one of
white's bishops
covers its escape route so um yeah i
think this will be levon aronian's first
long think of the game okay well levon
aronian being one of the he's not the
he's not by any means old but he's been
in the chess game for a long time
one of the players in this tournament
who's been in the game for
for the longest but but he looks quite
confident with this online chess
that we would think that the younger
newer players would be best at
yeah definitely you know he is very
experienced
over the board chess does it trump
whoops
whoopsie daisy sorry about that
so yeah you definitely that that doesn't
necessarily mean that that would
translate very well
to online chess but of course you know
he is showing it is possible to do these
things
but i think a lot of it is to do with
his chess experience you know he is so
used to playing classical chess you know
controlling the santa i've nicknamed him
mr santa
and he could use that to kind of
transfer onto online chess
where it isn't just about speed it's
also about getting good positions but
you do because you do have to remember
that he gets
he does get extra 10 seconds per move
so if you calm your mind you are able to
just go and go
okay and use your experience yeah and i
think that the moment to spend time on
the clock is when you're
creating a new plan these players
they'll be trying to think ahead now the
next three or four moves
how to put that how to place their
pieces which pieces to trade off
what they want to end up with um at the
end of the game so
that's why he's spending this time
that's why he will be thinking about the
center and all his favorite things
all chess players they have different
tastes different styles as well um so
it'll be fascinating to see
what levon comes up with and how magnus
will reply
i think magnus still needs to kind of
find his groove find his rhythm he will
need to speed up
very shortly actually the more you know
i'm looking at magnus's move it
seems so innocuous just to shift the
king one little square to the left
and now i'm thinking you made this big
point david that the
that lavon's king cannot do the same so
there might be some
danger that a rook could start looking
at that black king and kind of go
there are some threats there so levon
has moved his knight
so he is directly attacking this light
this dark squared bishop that magnus has
that's right if we bring up the board we
can see why levon played that move
we talked about in this last position
black's king it cannot shuffle across
one square it cannot copy white because
the bishop is covering
um that very important escape route for
the black king therefore
he brought his knight back attacking
that bishop trying to trade it off and
magnus has replied
very very quickly he just moves his
bishop forward one square eyeing up the
black knight but also keeping up this
x-ray um covering black's escape route
with the king white wants to shuffle his
rook across next
and eye up uh the black monarch so yeah
very nice move by magnus carlsen he's
speeding up he's
he's finally trying to get in that
groove i think levon he needs to get rid
of that bishop as soon as he can
and they are looking very focused and
very like in the moment here
uh already we can see them just so
focused
yeah we still do have to wonder where is
magnus playing from
any guesses well somewhere with the
beach that's all we know
uh judging from his instagram it's
somewhere on the beach yeah that's right
david where do you think um i can't even
remember what a warm country feels like
actually we do see a tweet there um a
guess that magnus is in bora bora
ah yes oh that's a good that's a good
choice yeah
bora bora yeah we have a tweet from
michael mcpatty it says
bora bora and uh yeah i'm thinking
mauritius what are you thinking
yeah i have no idea
all right well wherever he is we do have
some moves uh what's happening
we do and actually that i highlighted
the power of white's dark square bishop
a moment ago and that bishop has now
left the board level of ronia was able
to trade his own bishop
for that very strong white peace and we
do see black's king has also stepped
forward capturing that white bishop last
move
and magnus carson he's such a calm
player he just drops his bishop back
um the white bishop has dropped back
opening up the line of that white rook
we mentioned
that isolated pawn that pawn in the
middle of the board social distancing
from the rest of its other pieces
um that pawn is going to be the focal
point of white's attack
white will use his bishop use his rook
use his knight to try and attack that
pawn a bit later on
level neronian he needs to keep that
pawn protected he needs
i mean he might have to go passive he
might have to use all of his pieces to
defend it
but it will revolve the next few moves
around that pawn
all right the lonely pawn mr lonely
is nice in the center there though but
it doesn't help if it's alone
yeah if it's alone it really needs some
support from a fellow pawn
because then black doesn't have to worry
whilst that pawn is all alone without
any company then it's going to be a big
source of tension
so white will do everything they can to
attack it and black will have to by
default do
everything they can to defend but why
does it have to be a pawn defending it
well it's it's to do with the fact that
uh
the the pawn is like the lowest value
it's only one point so it doesn't really
matter if a queen
is attacking a defended pawn by a fellow
pawn because the queen can attack
everything she likes but she's never
gonna take that pawn because she's never
gonna trade herself for a pawn that's
worth one point
but whilst a porn is all alone then
it's possible for that piece to capture
that pawn
and so therefore it's just just
therefore it's all alone
no company and so therefore it does need
to be continuously protected
and this will always give the attacker
the edge because you will feel like okay
i'm putting pressure
and it might be tricky for lavon just to
kind of go passive and just try and hold
the thought
that's right i mean pieces especially
blacks knights here knights are such
great pieces when they're attacking
things when they're jumping about when
they're causing trouble
you don't want those knights tied down
to one square defending just a mere pawn
worth only one point but at the moment
that's what they they have to do
blacks knights they won't be able to
jump around they have to take this
defensive role
um that's why we normally want pawns
protecting each other pawns
they can keep each other um nicely
kind of lined up these make these pretty
patterns the pieces they should be doing
the hard work jumping around trying to
create threats trying to create
checkmate ideas
yeah um and maybe if we bring up the
board we can see
magnus carson's plan over the next
couple of moves he's dropped this bishop
back
um okay we've mentioned the game will
revolve around this pawn
he's dropped his bishop back with the
last move white is going to jump it
forward
in a moment attacking this paw there's
paw paw pawn in the middle of the board
white's knight at the moment and rook
are already ganging up against it one
more piece
might overwhelm the black army exactly
and uh look at the clock it has gone
under five minutes you you told me
ivanka
less than five minutes some sort of
clock goes off in your head yeah a
little
a little indicator goes off and you
start to feel the heat
and when you're under one minute oh that
is when the tension
rises and uh yeah and seven seconds we
know that the brain goes out of the
window
and then the trigger happy hand gets
ready and whatever happens is just
random
all right okay well we did have a move
by levonorone and then after a few
seconds here
the bar just shifted towards magnus what
happened yeah that's right so levon
there he's pushed the pawn on the right
side of the board um he wants to keep
pushing it he wants to open up his rook
in the corner
and that rook is on a semi-open line
right now look at stockfish now
the computer hates it he just
hates the move i am very curious that's
right and actually stockfish is just
suggesting one move for white
if we bring up the board we can show
what that move is
does that mean that white only has one
move here there's not just one move
there's plenty of moves but i think
maybe only one move to
get keep the advantage and to make sure
that that advantage stays
at a kind of very high rate and has
magnus carson played it he hasn't played
that move
white's idea should have been maybe to
push this pawn forward basically just
preventing black
from opening up this line for the rook
black wants to open up this line by
pushing his pawn forward
white should prevent this plan just uh
pushing a pawn forward it looks nice and
calm it's not
obvious at all for a human but um
i think it's always good to stop an
opponent's kind of active plan if you
see what they're going to do stopping it
is a good idea
instead magnus carson brought his bishop
forward attacking his pawn as we
mentioned
levon brought his king forward that's
very brave
um i have a nickname for this type of
king it's called a spartan king you know
named after the warriors of sparta
but basically that king should not be
out there in the front because that is
just
way too dangerous scary yeah
okay and then you can see magnus has
immediately lined up his
rook to start staring down at the king
oh wow you have some threats in the air
don't we david yeah that's right
and now actually the computer evaluation
if we see stockfish at the bottom there
it thinks that
moving that black king shuffling it
across one square that's the only way
for black
to actually pretty much not lose on the
spot there's only one move now
all other moves we can see the other two
suggestions they gave white an advantage
of plus
three or more he did find it he has
found it yeah that's right so
at the moment the advantage it says one
point for white that's
1.7 that's an advantage but at the
moment it's nothing concrete it's not
winning yet
okay anything over three over four that
starts to become very decisive
um so ironian he's on the defensive can
he hold things together can magnus
carlsen
can he find a way to turn that advantage
into a material game maybe can he grab a
pawn
can he get at the black king well the
clock is ticking so we know that with
time pressure
everything can happen and i will mention
that two games in this first round have
finished taree krishna and rasheeda
grava played the draw
and so has zanish geary and jana okay i
see the moves flourishing here what's
happening
that's right so i think we have to bring
up the analysis board a lot has been
happening
just those last couple of moves black's
king is in the middle of the board here
we saw it shuffle across one square
white's knight came up and gave a check
to that king the king has to run
but instead of retreating to safety
levon said no i'm not scared
i'm going to put my king in the middle
of the board whoa
that is a very brave spartan king i
actually i'm obsessed with a
kind of a game right now is called king
of the hill and the whole point of the
whole game is not to checkmate
it's to get your king to the middle of
the board and this king it's
um well maybe they've been playing okay
but unfortunately this is chess this is
chess that's right and will this king
become
the strongest piece on the board or will
it just get checkmated um
we see magnus carson he didn't really
hesitate he just grabbed a pawn here
white's knight is on the rim again it's
offside at the moment but
he has snatched a pawn black meanwhile
is put using his knight to try and
create some threats maybe to go for the
white king
maybe also to just to go for this pawn
and wow
magnus carson has just ignored that he's
brought his knight back
wow i'm shocked by that last move um
he's just
saying to lavon okay take that pawn i
dare you
um lots of stuff is going to happen
there um i think white's rook is about
to enter the game
as well and black's king might be in no
man's land
yeah exactly that's so so
risky to put the king out there in the
middle of the board when you have two
rooks and a knight and a bishop coming
at you i think it's just way too risky
to even think about snatching that pawn
um yeah because like you're right
completely right the the rook that's on
the right side that's doing absolutely
nothing
will now start attacking that rook and
start
menacing and creating some horrible
horrible threats against
that uh yeah i must admit one of the
beauty
beautiful things about chess is um well
when you see a position like this
and the king is stuck in the middle of
the board
in places where it really should not be
going
and it's like the kind of like sadistic
side where you just go well
this was of your own doing isn't it or
he's just feeling extremely confident
today
it might turn out to be a master stroke
it might be a moment of genius
you always hear about these genius moves
when you sacrifice the queen obviously
yeah very bad idea to sacrifice the king
but
then again if white fails to checkmate
that king then that king is perfectly
placed for the end game
um kings are always really good in the
center of the board if there's no chance
to get them getting checkmated they're
just a very useful
kind of attacking piece so um if that if
that black king survives
it probably won't but if it does survive
then um
lavon will look like a genius and levon
has moved he has moved now that pawn
went on yeah it's it's a very very
sneaky move i actually
love this move that lavone has played
because yes he's offering a second ball
but he's just thinking along the same
lines that david is saying
if he can exchange some pieces then it's
going to be a great aching game king
that we're seeing there in the center
and so that's all he wants give up a
pawn doesn't matter
and he's going to trade rooks and then
you can see that magnus is just not
playing ball but you know the bar
doesn't quite approve of magnus's
yeah that last choice by magnus carson
it's a very kind of passive move it's
just using that rook to defend
a pawn if we bring up the board we can
see levon he actually
well this is a sacrifice it wouldn't
even have crossed my mind this is how
strong these players are
he's pushed the pawn forward it looks
like it's just giving up another pawn
but if white captured
we would have seen maybe a trade of
rooks or more likely
black's knight would have taken this
pawn attacking the white rook
attacking this pawn as well black's
knight suddenly looking really good the
king is now nice and safe
nothing can attack it white doesn't have
any pawns to give check to that king
instead magnus carlsen was forced to go
on the defensive with his rook defending
this pawn but rooks don't like to be
passive
they don't like to be defending things
that last move by levon i think was
extremely clever
um and here we see his rook wow wow
jumping up the board
that we call that a rook lift um the
rook might oh but let's across later
yeah the bar though i'm wondering is
there a
um is there a tactical reason is there a
kind of a concrete reason that might be
bad
if that rook move if there's no
immediate punishment then i think it's
very useful that rook is slightly more
active
than it used to be it's up to magnus now
with only three minutes
uh and counting on his clock to try and
find a way to get to that black king is
all going to revolve around that
whether that king is a strength right
now and one of the great things about
chess
is yes the bar might be jumping and
disliking the choices but you have to
remember these are two
humans playing with all the
psychological pressure
of a two humans and they'll be thinking
you know i know magnus will
be thinking right now oh look at that
rook it just lifted up
perhaps the other rook will come and
join it and suddenly there will be
pressure against my pawn
how am i going to check mate this king
that is there where it shouldn't be
and again that's going to take time and
psychological burden so i'm
super fascinated by this position
because tension is
building up on the right side definitely
and both players now under
three minutes minus going down to two
minutes on the clock now
it will get intense and i will also
mention that another game has ended in
draw the game between
donald dubo and timor jabo so we have
three draws in this first round
so far david this position between
magnus and
levon is it a draw is
no i don't it anything is happening at
the minute and i'm loving
magnus's last move because you know we
mentioned that there was a lot of
tension on the right hand side
well this is magnus's attempt to clarify
it now he's saying to
lavonna do something with that pawn i
don't want it on my half anymore
and uh yeah lavone has to take a choice
that's right actually black's only two
pieces in white's half of the board
is that knight in the center and also
that black pawn and with his last move
he's trying to kick both of them out of
the position
um so that's a very strong idea by
magnus carson black is probably forced
to trade off a set of pawns now
and then he will have to retreat his
knight and retreating a night when your
king is in the center of the board that
night that black knight is keeping the
king safe
it's not what levon aronian wants to do
i think at this point as well he's only
got two minutes on this clock with such
a weak king
he just needs to think okay survival is
all about survival if he can survive the
next five ten moves he'll still have
chances
but he can't let his clock tick down
under one minute and he can't
let white get out of that king exactly
and uh there you can see that lavon is
desperate with his knight trying to keep
it as actively as possible and
magnus moving his rook to the center
honda there's been some
maneuverings with the knight super
quickly actually yeah both players are
playing very quickly there and there is
a saying that a knight is a king's best
friend
um knights are great defenders of the
king so we see levon
that's why he's placed both of his
knights around his king those knights
will keep that black king
nice and safe in the center well i stay
safe
relatively safe that black king might
have to retreat sooner or later
meanwhile black is attacking a pawn with
his knight
the onus is on magnus carson actually he
needs to find a way to get to that king
it's not obvious to me at first um also
we see the computer valuation it's not
really sure stockfish
it gives white an advantage but again
it's not quite a winning advantage
it's kind of more about the human
perspective it's not easy to play with
white um he needs to find a way to get
his rooks coordinated
i would want to somehow line those rooks
up together maybe not right now
um he steps his root forward one square
protecting just protecting one pawn
and now they you know the great thing
about magnus's position is there is a
lot of harmony
like all the pieces are on the left side
there there's a very clear kind of aim
but they still want to get out that
very weak pawn that black has in the
center that's all alone
and lavonne is just playing with his
knights
that's right um yeah that's a very
sophisticated maneuver that last one
that night retreat
um black is bringing his pieces back i'm
generally not a fan of retreating unless
you have to
so i'm not a huge fan of that last move
that being said blacks knights they're
coordinating very well
between them they cover a lot of central
squares
i think the reason black played that
last move is because the pawn we talked
about that isolated pawn in the middle
black's weak pawn
needed extra defense so um levon forced
to go on the defensive again
magnus carlsen though he's soon going to
tick under one minute on the clock
and this is such a kind of difficult
unorthodox position it's very hard to
handle for both sides
therefore i'm starting to think actually
the last few moves have gone in levon
aronian's favor
an extra minute on the clock and a very
kind of nice centralized king
ready for a race later yeah that's
i think long term it might favor him
it's all about whether magnus can find
something short yeah and he's just gone
under the one minute mark
which does mean that the panic is going
to start creeping
in and we might start seeing the ugly
side of online chess
when players just make random moves oh
okay
and magnus has offering a night trade
and uh levon
again i'm really kind of very intrigued
by levon's
choices i wouldn't necessarily have
predicted them myself he has just
reacted that by pushing a pawn on the
right side
that's right um i mean the players are
ticking low on the clock here
but that um i would love to bring up the
board but actually we still see a night
trade
and i just wanted to say lavon's last
move pushing this pawn forward
stops white from ever getting to the
black king he's preventing any checks
and we do see after this move was played
a set of knights leaves the board um
white's rook has jumped into the enemy
territory it's jumped into the black
camp attacking a pawn attacking a knight
but after black jumps forward with this
knight suddenly it's all
i mean anything can happen now black is
attacking the spawn attacking the spawn
both sides they're losing he's doing
he's doing it and uh the pawn has
advanced oh my god we're gonna see
maximum tension but what i like about
levon's position now is that he no
longer has a very weak pawn in this in
the center
you know look at them they are nicely
connected and if you look at white's
pawns
they're a little bit loose oh but magnus
is really
playing quickly that's right playing
quickly and
you know i just love the way that he's
playing quickly and putting
lavon under pressure because there is
that psychological problem
that white has these two lovely pawns on
the left side
that's right those whites two pawns on
the left side there long term they might
become a factor but they're not very
advanced right now
if they get to the end of the board they
will become a new queen at the moment
though
um they're not kind of deciding they're
not deciding the game
but uh definitely lavon has to do
something so oh
super exciting he said that in games
can't be uh tense
it might come down to a pawn race who
can get that pawn to the end of the
board
first and black's pawns they're slightly
further advanced they're slightly closer
to the end of the board
meanwhile though white is a pawn up just
temporarily and black will be going
after white's remaining pawn on the
right side there um
meanwhile that black king is survived
that's the main thing for love on i
think that'll be a huge
kind of psychological victory for him um
magnus leaning forward
less than a minute on the clock for the
world championship yes the pressure is
on
and of course there's uh the king is
surviving and and certainly thriving
actually
that's right looks nicely centralized
white is attacking that king now white
gives check
with his rook that king can retreat um i
think it should retreat to attack the
white rook
that's giving it check um levon aronian
still moving extremely fast he's still
got almost two minutes almost double
magnus
uh magnus carson's time on the clock
magnus actually played five six moves so
quickly he gained a minute
um but now he's back down um back down
lower on time and
um lavon he's got a choice to make he
can retreat his king to two squares to
two dark squares attacking that white
rook
i think though that's not a huge
difference he should just move now
move first think later it's it's all
about speed right now
yes absolutely it is going to be about
speed it's going about
decision making and uh oh the clock is
ticking
so make a move and it's actually very
difficult decision where to go with the
king you obviously want to attack
the the rook but do you go to the center
in which case you might be
vulnerable to the other rook that white
has or
do you just simply go to the other side
to the right side of the board in which
case the king might be cut off from the
action
difficult choices to make that's right i
mean a difficult choice for level on
ironian but
he should not be spending more than half
of his time on this one move
he should just retreat his king and try
and work out what's going on a bit later
on
um it's this is the type of position
type of situation i've been in so many
times you've only got one minute on the
clock you just need to look two or three
moves ahead i think he's looking a bit
too deep now
and he's tick he's soon going to take
under 30 seconds yeah
just uh make the move level on okay so i
would go to the right where would you go
i'd also
yes right is right um
lavon just seems like such a cool
customer today he's just under 30
seconds
under 20 seconds remember seven seconds
is when the brain is out of oh he has
moved to the center i didn't quite like
that i was afraid that suddenly white
would be
able to use all the rooks okay so
there's been some trades and uh yeah
we're gonna see the
the immortal lines it's a race it's a
race that's right
and um the knight and the bishop have
left the board black traded that
beautiful night in the center i didn't
think he wanted to keep it
um but he yeah unfortunately he was
forced to trade it off
and now we do see that blacks rooks they
were ganging up on this white pawn on
the right side
therefore magnus carlsen just defends it
nice and calmly magnus he's banking on
the fact he has an extra pawn
and those two pawns on the left side
there they are connected connected pawns
are the best they can support each other
right exactly they can just come up the
board hand in hand
and can be nicely supported by all the
pieces you know absolutely
i'm loving magnus's position i mean the
only question for me now is whether
this is enough to win i think it is and
10 seconds for a level
and that last move he did find a good
move so it was time well spent
it was a good investment there he
brought his rook forward and actually if
we look across the rank there
um the black rook is stopping the white
pawn on the left side from moving
forward blacks
could just capture that pawn therefore
magnus carlsen decides
your king was active it's time to
activate my king yeah and white's king
steps forward and black
you know still with the presence of
those two rooks on the board i mean the
king still isn't very safe
you know it can get caught in the action
yeah lavon is not letting his king have
a very luxurious life in this game
he's just uh forced to join in on the
action
yeah we talked about relex relaxing over
christmas and that king has not had a
relaxing
relaxing first game we thought he'd just
ease into the action but
um that black king um yeah i think at
the moment
as white i would just be trying to get
those pawns running as
quickly as possible magnus carson
meanwhile he
brings his rook forward those two white
rooks now are ganging up on that pawn
in the middle the pawn that's been
isolated and lonely for so long
at that point it looks quite likely to
drop off um
okay levon he blocks the attack of one
of the white rooks
yeah i think we have to bring up the
ball to show that moment that was so
dramatic
um in this position um magnus carlsen
he did miss an opportunity levon
aronian's last move bringing the rook
across one square
magnus the first thing we teach
beginners actually the first thing we
should always look for are checks and
captures
he could have played this move pushing
his pawn forward giving check to the
black king
it looks like a sacrifice this pawn can
be taken but he's opened up
a line against the undefended black rook
and this is what we mean
by the trigger happy hand because i'm
sure the hand just made the move
and then afterwards i think i saw the
slight shake from magnus where he
realized oh
wow and we saw it on the bar as well it
was completely winning for magnus
and then one move later missed it it's a
draw
well the bar is saying it's a draw can
magnus still win this game
it's very difficult now white king is at
the bottom there it's nice and safe but
it's not active and now he's tucked his
coin king away in the corner
kings are such good pieces in the end
game black is attacking with his rook
um eyeing up one of white's pawns and
black's king is now eyeing up the white
rook
black's king and rook has just fantastic
pieces better than the white
counterparts therefore despite the fact
white's still a point ahead i think
levon
should be able to hold this game he
brings his king back he's going to start
pushing his pawn in the middle there
yeah he's shaking his head yeah it's
still not that easy you know because you
know
these connected past pawns if they start
mobilizing that's it
white is going to win and it's all going
to be about you know these
double connected passports the white
house on the left and that center
pawn that black has that is completely
unchallenged and is passed
i love the norwegian expression for past
porn free i always think
[Laughter]
so uh yeah this is so so fascinating and
it's super sharp
yeah that's right and although the
computer so we see stockfish there it
does give a tiny advantage for white
and seven second for magnus oh you know
what happens in seven seconds
okay and it's advanced the king
and now we can see that pawn pushing and
the white's wreck is so
passive that's right and i was going to
say as
the computer does declare that the
position is pretty much a draw
but there's definitely chances in human
terms anything could happen white's
pawns could start running free
or that black pawn in the middle we said
it was weak for so long it slowly
started to advance now
and if white's pieces kind of can't
break out of their defensive formation
right now
then actually i think it's actually it's
maybe easier to play with black despite
the fact he's
born down so very tricky situation
magnus finally getting those pawns
running yeah
and levon attacks the white king that is
czech at the moment
yes very tense i still can't believe he
didn't see the move to win a rook
it's the type of thing magnus would see
i think nine times 99 times out of a
hundred
um this was just that one time he he
this is the kind of
this is the thing you know so you you're
getting ready with the mouse to kind of
make your response that you just don't
think about the possibilities
and i'm i'm pretty sure he would have
seen it like a second later yeah and
i mean the viewers at home got to
remember these guys are human too
grandmaster's blunder
as well and the reason magnus didn't see
it probably is he just thought okay
aronia's so strong
subconsciously he doesn't expect him to
make a blunder he doesn't expect him to
lose a rooker
move so he wasn't looking for the win
and now we see
black's king is entering the white half
of the board
trying to get those pawns and those
white horns they're still connected
but that black king is so strong
attacking them right now i think black
has a few moves he could even
trade off a set of pawns um by
pushing there we go pushing his pawn on
the right side of the board
those pawns have disappeared um well one
of them has at least
black's rook now it has a choice do you
take that pawn um
just above it or does it slide across
and capture another pawn
wouldn't it be an advantage to take the
one connected to the other yeah that's
that would be the instinct
okay this is something we didn't expect
okay so he has pushed his own
pawn i really think he would do that and
uh now magnus
has just blocked the pawn with his king
but i still think
even though it was unexpected it
probably is just a draw
it is um white unfortunately can't
defend um
that pawn um black's king is about to
capture that
pawn in front of it right now um okay he
gives a check first the black rook will
swing across in a moment and capture
that pawn
yeah unfortunately one pawn is not
enough in a rook in game to win black's
king is simply too active
yeah and he set the final trick but of
course lavone doesn't
has spotted that and uh now you see king
versus king yep
and a draw neither side has enough
materials left to trap me yes
wow what a thrilling game that was so
tense and
that one moment as well just a huge
blunder by i mean
mutual blindness both of them just i'd
love to interview the masters just see
whether they saw it
uh see whether they realized okay you
can just uh see uh magnus
uh you can one of the things they did
tell us from the skilling open
was that they did quickly check through
the game just to make sure that they
hadn't made any big blunders or anything
and i can think see magnus doing that
right now
and i probably he's gonna dawn on him
that oops
he had a win because we couldn't really
see it on his face when the move was
made that he
if he actually realized i think this is
maybe now is the moment magnus is going
through the game
and i think maybe this is the moment he
realizes he
couldn't want to work there maybe he's
maybe he knows he was winning at some
point he's just trying to figure out
when he looks a bit confused
like he maybe has that feeling at some
point